tout est plutôt calme et notre polémiste
jean jules bourdes un temps une question
a suivi ortega qui lui répond on a
toujours rêvé de répondre à gilles
verdez quand il prend la parole
regarde merci sylvie 4 avec nous aussi
louis ortéga maire
et c'est vrai que sylvie cette histoire
elle est complètement folle elle boom
ascione tous les soirs c'est devenu un
véritable feuilleton
oui gilles moi je voudrais redire à
sylvie ortega les yeux dans les yeux ce
que je pense
non monsieur mais la mélamine avait mis
loana sous dépendance et c'est dangereux
voile absolument pas d'accord ok gilles
verdez alors la balle à elle ne répond
pas on fait elle fuit mais tout au long
de la conversation elle fuit elle ne
veut pas répondre exactement sur ce qui
s'est passé pour le moment elle reste
calme et assez structuré dans le
discours deux minutes plus tard sylvie
voulais absolument revenir sur une
séquence de la veille qu'elle n'a pas du
tout digéré regarde ce qui s'est passé
hier soir est extrêmement grave très
grave
sylvie si tu me regardes j'ai un message
pour toi mon père il est mort en 2013 tu
as voulu parler de lui eh ben il est au
paradis et aux pisse au cul voilà oui
d'accord
ah ouais mais voilà c'est une folle une
c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire sur cette
seconde s dirais c'est mal joué
donc là la question non je n'en faut pas
rigoler mais c'est vrai que ça me fait
un peu rire moi je trouve que ça fait un
peu les nouvelles tv novella mal joué
mais lovren fait que tout était la
mairie yonnel et série club le casting
était fou alors vous avez été nombreux à
réagir
20h59 les esprits s'échauffent latence
sur monde sur le plateau entre benjamin
castaldi et sylvie ortega et là c'est le
clash
nous répondons calmez vous redescendez
son année d'âge mais parce que numéro un
après
debbie tebbs connerie mais nan mais
vas-y continue à la gerbe et amer parce
vous êtes une mythomane cratérisée
n'avait jamais été marié avec deux
villes françaises
mais ça m'a donné moi je regarde droit
dans les bois je n'ai pas envie parce
que j'ai peur j'ai eu très peur pour
vous pendant que vous êtes en train de
raconter vos conneries de merde moi
pendant ce temps dans mon lit le soir je
lis nietzsche ou froide ok d'accord
alors là bas j'ai vingt questions mais
bon effectivement d'abord franchement
elle a menti en direct parce
qu'effectivement elle dit qu'elle n'a
jamais insulté
ça fait depuis qu'elle est bien c'est
quoi ces sources qui ont alors compris
oui ça fait une semaine que quelques
coureurs les petites les petits plateaux
de petites émissions mais un coup à la
dcsa halalisation émission froisser le
buzz ne se mettaient pas le dire peu
importe j'ai des images quoi elle dit
que j'étais un film de julie elle
parodie abdallah fils de hama est allée
des horreurs sur ma famille là
aujourd'hui à la lancée elle pensait
lancer une énorme révélation c'est
d'ortega puisqu'elle à dire et en plus
c'est même pas le petit fils des
montants mais pauvre idiote c'est mais
j'ai jamais que c'est bon c'est mon
grand père puisque il a doublé ma mère
donc a dit cette femme en plus alors à
laver à lavernhe et ailleurs qui était
assez étonnant parce que j'ai trouvé
qu'il était assez fluctuant en fait oui
excusez moi c'était un peu inquiétant je
vous écoute et je me traite je peux dire
ce que j'ai vécu à côté parce que
j'étais à côté
oui qu'elle avait des pièces à
conviction sur toile à la détruire
n'importe quoi à la finale elle soumet
sa conviction son maire y ait là quoi
des mails à claude albinet de n'importe
quoi comme aldi ouvertement qu'elle
était mariée à l'éduction c'est ce qui
tue le betis études c'est un mensonge
total total
mais je vais vous dire une chose pire
c'est qu'elle a demandé à héberger a
épousé ludovic chancel après sa mort
ouais c'est pour vous donner un peu le
degré de la dame et moi j'ai rien contre
elle sauf que son seul but je vous dis
cyril honnêtement et on les donnait la
parole et on était obligé parce
qu'effectivement dans cette émission on
le dit à chaque fois cantona parole
alain on la rend à l'autre mais le
problème de cette dame c'est qu'elle
veut juste faire parler d'elle alma
copieusement insulter tous les jours par
un stage sur snapshot en traitant de
tous les noms je n'ai pas répondu une
chose que je veux surtout pas alimenter
le buzz mais au bout d'un moment faut
pas laisser dire des choses qui sont
fausses série parce que c'est pas c'est
pas vrai
bien plus réussie qu'on qu'on l'a
insulté alors que aller horrible cette
dame dit les choses épouvantables
vraiment si je vous le dis j'ai fait n'a
effectivement parce qu'au bout d'un
moment c'est quoi votre machine
si vous voulez vous voulez pas vous
voulez envoyer non mais non mais lisez
là nous l'avons retrouvé à la lettre et
élise est la seule à s'y retrouver
on connaît un méritas sylvie ortega dans
le débat je lui ai dit les yeux dans les
yeux ce que je pense et dell mais c'est
une combattante à une combattante elle
vient elle s'en prend plein la gueule
l'avait elle vient répliqué elle a le
mérite ce clash avec benjamin on pourra
pas dire que c'est quelqu'un qui parle
par derrière elle vient dire les choses
ici et ça je trouve qu'à une franchise
chez elle sans doute un peu délirante et
que je comptais sur le fond mais cette
franchise là elle est réelle elle a su
cristalliser vote laissant à madame vous
croyez bon et reprenait donc madame vous
croyez bon de courir les plateaux télé
dans le but d'un jeu de majorer
publiquement le présent mais elle a donc
pour objet de vous rappeler que la loi
punit les injures publiques par la
condamnation à une amende de 12 mille
euros outre les dommages intérêts voilà
même si je comprends votre attitude que
souffrant d'un manque de notoriété vous
tentez de faire parler de vous à tout
prix y compris par des moyens illégaux
nous ne partageons pas du tout la même
philosophie à la moindre nouvelle injure
et à quelques moyens que ce soit je
porte je vais porter plainte
voilà
voilà les combos lecture car oui mais
bon on fait sur la tête j'ai pas une
image de sérieux maux des bénéfices je
peux finir à quoi c'est pas fini bah non
c'est une purge de l'armée non mais ne
vous entendre dire c'est une purge
alors je vous supporte plus je suis pas
venu alors enfin vous comprendrez
aisément que ce corps si cogeco est le
contiennent aucune formule de politesse
madame à castanet merci beaucoup qui
m'écrit juste on voulait vue sur le
clash entre benjamin et sylvie j'ai eu
du mal à contenir
oui parce que c'est vrai que c'était
chaud et j'ai eu comme d'habitude
malheureusement un fou rire
je vous explique comment ça s'est passé
l'ebit chaud on est toujours 5
évidemment on n'est toujours pas évident
[Musique]
quand on l'emmène n'y a pas que moi il
ya le chauffeur avec moi
d'accord ouais d'accord ouais ça votre
idée est là bien sûr
21h04 les choses sérieuses commencent
eryl prayer amie de loana fait son
entrée sur le plateau
et là c'est plus la même limonade et il
vient dire ses quatre vérités à sylvie
qui n'a pas trop envie de l'écouter et
préfère pousser la chansonnette regarde
ce qu'il a à faire entériner les bons
rails les bons airs il hérite et
l'accueil des montres et autres brouyère
leur mitonne un autre vous hier lors mis
alors allez-y vous allez rigoler
m'allonger une annonce à faire
[Musique]
l'émission la culotte
alors et là il est 21h 6 et là je vous
le dis on a fait un truc qu'on a jamais
fait dans tp mpc l'avare de tpm peu la
barre vidéo assistance
voilà je vous explique donc c'est sur
twitter c'est la folie des internautes
sont morts de rire mais à 21h06 on va
passer un cap on assiste à l'un des plus
gros clash de l'histoire de la télé tout
le monde sur le plateau est choqué et
boucher vous à la maison aussi parce que
c'est vrai que c'est parti c'est parti
en cacahuète regardez bien on vous a
préparé donc là vaart et pmp pour bien
voir tout ce que vous avez raté comme
dans un match de foot regarde c'est toi
qui aime bien de sortir et tu peux plus
[Musique]
d'ailleurs ce que tu as osé dire et hier
soir
alors ça c'est vrai que est là là là là
c'était complètement nicolas pernikoff
vous êtes et faux où vous êtes mort de
rien un mois mais d'abord je suis
choquée parce que c'est quand même assez
c'est assez fou c'est ça c'est ça fait
peur et puis demandez moi j'ai flippé
sur le plateau mais c'est vrai que je
suis parti en cacahuète parce que elle
arrêtait pas de bouger à côté de lui
avec benjamin qui tournait qui tournait
le dos il y avait des discussions
apocalyptique et puis un moment donné
quand il arrive et qu'elle commence à
chanter love me tender en se balançant
dans tous les sens c'était lunaire donc
j'étais ailleurs - gt gt plus large
était plus à une quasi bah moi je pense
qu'à partir du moment où on voit que
tout est sécurisé et c'est là on peut
rigoler parce que c'est vrai que sur le
coup on peut se dire bon qu'est-ce qui
se passe
mais là là c'est sûr qu'on a vu la
section on peut rigoler parce que c'est
ça sort du on a rarement vu ça en
plateau fin il ya eu des exemples il ya
des années mais là là ces dernières
décennies un truc comme ça on n'y a pas
assisté
et là on était tous mort de rire moi
j'étais en direct sur twitter et je
voyais les gens lire ça a été juste
regarder on va voir ses balesi non dean
voilà je suis mort castaldi incroyable
parce que là c'est avant le fou rire
quelle tristesse de voir chère et elle
vit se déchirer un beau que j'embrasse
elle me termine la faute on dirait la
présentation d'apple madoff
voilà non mais ça a été ça a été énorme
et l'avare tpb s'est arrêté sur un autre
bon vous avez peut-être raté c'est
lorsqu'il est arrivé sur le plateau il
nous a dit qu'il regrettait d'avoir
insulté sylvie artesia la veille oui
mais ces regrets
regardez énormément de tweets là dessus
c'est à dire 21h c'est raté leur set je
regrette je regrette bat énormité
vraiment le cas tout d'abord je tiens à
reconnaître que je me suis emporté dans
votre émission et que ce n'est pas ma
façon d d'abord je tiens à reconnaître
que je me suis emporté dans votre
émission et que ce n'est pas ma façon
[Applaudissements]
et alors que ça partait en cacahuète
chez nous je me suis permis de vous
faire pendant ce temps là regardez petit
récap regarder sur les autres chaînes
qui n'a rêvé de modou fall à la fois
dire quelqu'un vous at il menacé
oui franc pour qui c'est toi à
l'intérieur d'un câble sous marin
l'information se transmet à la vitesse
de la lumière
les droits ce que tu as osé dire hier
soir m'aider mais c'est une maladie qui
coûte trop cher qui coûtent trop cher au
système de santé
ils sont tombés amoureux de la région
ils en connaissent tous les bons plans
et bonnes nouvelles ils vont nous les
faire partager
on est en direct on aimerait vraiment
que ça se passe bien et 21h10 si un truc
qui a énormément fait réagir sur les
réseaux sociaux
c'est lorsqu'il s'est levé pour aller
vers sylvie la sécurité arrive et j'ai
repoussé mes potes mon ami qui est là
qui m'ont la mia j'oublie ses bons amis
depuis des années je vais te parler
après d'ailleurs j'ai repoussé au delson
alors j'ai lu beaucoup de conneries sur
les réseaux qui dirigeait que j'ai
repoussé au 17 pour que l'embrouillé
continue alors que pas du tout on va
revoir cette scène et j'ai dit un truc
énorme
j'ai dit on n'est pas dans un gangster
ici écoutez bien cette phrase je ne sais
pas d'où elle est sortie
s'il vous plaît bien sûr c'est que je
t'aime
ah non mais c'est vrai parce que dans je
trouvais qu avait pas un grand danger je
vous dis la vérité
non voilà donc je me suis dit voilà
c'est pas la peine non plus de paniquer
les téléspectateurs y avait pas un
énorme danger entre eric et c'est une
dureté gars je vois là je pense qu'on
pouvait maîtriser la fia net sur
l'adrénaline qui vous avait fait voilà
et le haut des tu sais que je t'aime mon
chéri filet puis sort que vous tous je
suis pas sûr oui un petit mot sur ce qui
s'est passé en coulisses hier soir parce
qu'on voyait essaie de récupérer les
bijoux de loana exact survie lui aurait
volé selon lui donc il a récupéré ses
bijoux et selon lui il manque des bijoux
ça c'est la première chose d'accord
ensuite j'ai des nouvelles de loana
loana est sorti de l'hôpital donc très
bonne nouvelle et on a une photo d'elle
sur laquelle elle est plutôt à l'air
plutôt que ça fait plaisir d'avoir comme
ça elle a repris les tournages et elle a
demandé ça c'est une info à couper cindy
ortega de toutes les scènes est à
refaire ces scènes censées murtagh a
d'abord pu à un moment où vous allez
continuer le le buy way d'accord alors à
la série que sur les réseaux sociaux
hier soir c'était la folie et un dernier
magnéto si la chaîne qui nous a demandé
également de le mettre parce que c'est
vrai que pour montrer voilà que je vous
dis le plateau a été maîtrisé grâce à
tout le monde
regardez c'est un plateau qui montre que
l'antenne a été largement maîtrisé hier
à 21h tous notamment regarde très bien
par les siens sur le plateau yonhap et
sortaient tous les régimes il a tout
compris et ses plaies il sortait tous
les deux arrêtez s'il vous plaît gardez
avait pas le droit
on veut pouvoir on va pouvoir discuter
gentiment sur ce plateau s'il vous plaît
là c'est n'importe quoi ne vous énervez
pas sylvie airs il on aimerait que vous
ayez un échange courtois même si vous
n'êtes pas d'accord mais alors c'est
vrai que c'était un moment incroyable
je sais pas comment voulez vous et moi
c'est un des plus grands moments que
j'ai vécus dans touche pas à mon poste
le mans paris - bizarrement j'ai été
très très mal à l'aise j'ai trouvé que
ça avait un côté un peu alors c'est la
société du spectacle mais je trouvais qu
hier c'est un peu dégénéré ça faisait un
peu votre ville un peuple scène est
grotesque c'est ce que j'ai ressenti
moins aussi à y aller mais non mais ils
étaient c'est à dire que moi j'étais un
peu comme nicolas c'est à dire qu'à la
fois il y avait 1
un truc de rire un peu d'exutoire comme
ça et en même temps j'étais très gênée
en même temps je savais pas où ça allait
aller voilà je trouve que c'était
bizarre et à aucun moment finalement
pensé en poste à luan a c'est à dire qu
on assister à ces deux énergumènes pb
alors ils n'ont alors qu'ils sont quand
même responsable de aussi de nos coûts
de ces deux saisons on va on va terminer
là dessus je vous dis lui énormément de
bruit et surtout je vous dis il ya
beaucoup plus grave
et franchement cette séquence hier pour
moi c'est une des séquences les plus
drôles l'histoire de thé pmp je n'ai
jamais autant ri de ma vie voilà
géraldine maillet va la revoir et vous
verrez qu'elle réglera ça